so we talked about our anti-bucket list
is there anything on your actual bucket
list would you okay here's the thing
we've talked about the Seven Wonders do
you think you'd actually want to go to
the Seven Wonders
what I want to go to is Machu Picchu why
do you have an obsession with Machu pics
you always bring it up okay okay for one
you've brought up match picture at least
three times okay for one okay a number
of things
for one I [__] love hiking right so
it'd just be dope as [__] to go hiking
in the mountains yeah two it's like the
only real reason I would want to like
visit South America
[Music]
no offense to South America but it's
like I don't have like the biggest like
uh you know uh interest in a lot of like
South America just personally maybe I
just don't know about it I don't know
but the one thing that I think would
just be really cool to do is to like go
to Machu Picchu and also like I know a
lot of friends who've been to Machu
Picchu and they say like just Peru in
general is just like a really dope
country to like just go and like explore
obviously dangerous but my favorite
thing to do is whenever I mention I want
to go to a South American country I'd be
like oh I want to get a I want to check
out Mexico and everyone from Mexico will
come out of the woodwork in my like live
stream chat and they'll be like don't
[Music]
if I mentioned Brazil everyone from
Brazil it's like no yeah that's yeah
that's the other problem is that like
whenever never bring up like a South
American country that I would hear from
someone who'd be like oh it's like for
example Mexico for example like you know
a friend of mine like uh worked in
Colombia for like three months uh early
this year and he said it was really
[__] dope and I was like okay cool
that would be really you know if you
said it was cool then you know I I would
be interested in I saw the photos and
everything it looks really cool but then
when I hit up my friend who is Brazilian
who lives in Japan they were just like
yeah don't it's not worth it so I'm like
which one is it I want to go but you
guys are telling me not to go it's like
that thing when you live in a place you
kind of you're always dogging on it
because you're like there's always
better stuff elsewhere yeah I really
don't appreciate the good stuff about
being there for sure for sure
um would you guys want to go to would
you want to go to something I like the
idea of going to South America but every
time like I've had similar experiences
so yeah anyone living in South America
do you have any recommendations on where
actually you'd recommend yeah what's a
country you would actually recommend
that's yeah or just a place where's the
place you recommend they're going to say
Machu Picchu that's not much man that
that'll be sad if like the top things to
do in South America Machu Picchu or
nothing else yeah
um what about like uh like a Caribbean
country I would like to go to a
Caribbean I would like to go to
Caribbean I want to go to Jamaica that
would be a lot of fun it just seems fun
yeah Jamaica yeah yeah the Caribbean
seems awesome yes yeah Caribbean
countries will be dope I mean I I also
want to go to like less beachy places as
well because I feel like you know I've
been to like Thailand enough times and
I'm not going to compare Thailand like
Inland countries you mean yeah I I
really want to see the Northern
landlocked yeah
maybe you want to go like
uh Joey I don't know there's a club I
found on Reddit that was like apparently
it was titled like uh Mongolian
traditional dish being prepared and it's
just like a guy smacking an ass cheek
and it was just air coming out of the
ash cheek I don't I don't I want to go I
don't know what the [__] it was but it
had me giggling because it just looks
ridiculous
it looked absurd yeah I want to see the
Northern Lights before yeah yeah I've
never seen the Northern Lights
um yeah I mean I'm Southeast Asian so
when we went on holidays we would avoid
cold countries like the [__] play
we're like oh we do we are not built for
this climate we did not survive Here and
Now That I'm Older I'm like yeah kind of
a Vibe is it because
you guys didn't have like the winter
clothes yeah pretty much is it you just
like you're like this is not worth
investing in a whole set of clothes do
you know how expensive winter jackets
are Jesus Christ
yo everything everything I bought was
like the you know you got hand-me-downs
I got like everything I bought was a
second hand from the [__] car boot
sale that was that was my fashion winter
jacket from a car boot shop it's
probably better than the Primark because
I don't remember they sell winter
jackets yeah does not sell winter
jackets
okay there's like winter jackets and
then there's like you know for British
Winters and then there is winter jackets
for if you're actually going to go
skiing or to an actual [__] country
like skiing you need some some like yeah
that's specialized gear because you need
like [__] that can roll in the snow can
get like a bunch of wind chill because
you're going fast like that's different
I mean if you go to a cold place
um it won't feel as cold as when you're
skiing because how what you're doing
it's just very different okay because
I've gone to cold places before and not
needed the winter jacket because it's
like oh you're [__] marriage I think
I think what I want to do now that I've
done quite a bit of traveling and I want
to definitely do more traveling is like
I just want to go to countries or places
that are kind of unconventional to go to
in terms of like tourism or like you
know like a country where like you would
never hear of anyone actually going to
places like that you know why do you
want to do that I don't know just
because I know so little about it and I
don't I know barely any anecdotes of
people going to those places and I'm
just I just want to figure out for
myself really just me and it's awesome
maybe not an alternative but yeah you
can go to North Korea you know I'm good
I'll stick to South Korea I'll stick to
South Korea well like you know like for
example like I wanna you know like I've
always said like I've always wanted to
like go to Antarctica or like Greenland
or like nothing to do in Antarctica well
I don't know
I can tell you I do know there is
I want to do that though because how
many people do you know other than most
stories that has been so Antarctica you
know like I don't know I feel like the
problem is at that point when you go to
Antarctica like how much the beach did
it yeah everything you're doing is is
you I had a guy who is an expert at this
is just is like toddlering you right
yeah he is doing everything for you know
at that point it's like you're not
really getting that experience and it's
like when people like climb Everest it's
like yeah because the [__] Sherpa is
carrying your ass all right you'd never
be able to do this alone yeah yeah it's
like are you really that sense of
accomplishment it's like did you really
do it or there's a [__] Sherpa who's
the goat who [__] save your ass did
this for you yeah yeah you've definitely
did some of it and I think it's still
valid you [__] climb this mountain or
whatever but yeah that's like I think
when you say like I want to go to
Antarctica I'm like man I just that
doesn't make any sense to me it's like
because you just you're not doing
anything you're some guy's taking care
of you yeah but I just I I just you know
I'm one of those people yeah I'm one of
those people that really values just
having that experience you know like
whether it is like something that was
like purely as you know because of my
actions and my actions alone it's just
the fact that it's just a cool story you
can tell you know like so like
Madagascar is another one where I'm just
like I just want to [__] go just to
see what it's like yeah or like you know
you see Prince Julian yeah I can see I
want to know if the animals are still
there you know is the zebra still there
I want to find out yeah I mean I I don't
know this is you know definitely
privileged to say but I just like
Comfort
unfortunately
I cannot shoot comfortably that's yeah
that's like a that's a big takeaway yeah
like I know some people you know like
you know go into third world countries
just to appreciate all of the things
that they have
um I do appreciate that and I'm gonna
continue appreciating but I appreciate
it if I said this I would get I would
get castrated by our audience okay
because appreciate it but only through
YouTube videos here's the thing the
reason I appreciate it is because I
haven't exactly been to a third world
country but I've been in the countryside
of Thailand which is like second world
country right it's not exactly you know
third world but I have stayed at some of
my family's places deep in the
countryside of Thailand where there's
[__] nothing to do there you [__] in
a Hole uh there is no flushable toilets
or anything like that and I'm like yeah
I like Comfort I do I do guys I do I I
very much I very much appreciate the
Comforts that I have and I'm going to
continue appreciating that I am luckily
privileged into like my confidence you
know I I don't look for a lot of things
I just want a nice bed I've slept on a
hard floor for like when you know being
a monk I I've I've done the [__] monk
life it's [__] great it's spiritual
you can learn a lot of things I like
having a bad guys yeah I mean
realistically I'm insane but like
realistic quickly I I also don't think I
could just like you know go to a third
world country just like immediately like
that without I think it would be a lot
easier in in my case personally if like
I I kind of went step by step you know
like you know like obviously you know
first of all and then like you know
experience a bunch of Second World
countries and like the way that they
live and the way that they like you know
spend their lives and then you know and
then progressively go down to the
thought like I don't think I could just
like [__] go to I thought you said
talk about like it's like like a like a
hot side of the pool so I gotta dip my
toes yeah yeah and then I gotta go fully
dude like as a child you couldn't just
like jump into the deep end that [__]
was scary you know you had to wean
yourself into it what blows one out of
these people who go to these like crazy
dangerous countries yeah yeah see I
can't do that I've almost seen this guy
I don't know what he was but he just
like kept getting stopped at like
military checkpoints but they were like
militia and they were just taking his
passport and stuff and he was like do I
get it back and he's like wait and it's
like oh my God yeah I never want to be
in a situation
I'm very open to like having new
experiences in my life but you know if I
go to a place I do want there to be you
know the basic infrastructure of stuff
that I am kind of like familiar with
yeah why are you laughing
the UK is a second world country because
they have the lack of yes
yeah they don't got [__] yeah
um I just want a good place to have a
nice meal as well that I could look
forward to that's all like that's this
list of countries is ever ever getting a
lot
of America Europe and some Asian
countries
yeah I mean you know I uh I'm I'm happy
I'm comfortable I'm comfortable but uh I
certainly I I've done enough traveling
I've put myself in enough experiences to
know what I am cool not experiencing you
know that's fair that's fair can't tries
to avoid cancer life
no no I think that's I think that's
exactly it's valid it's one of those
things where like you have to be careful
how you say stuff like that right
because obviously they can come up for
us just being elitist or just being like
[__] those guys but I I get it I think
you said it right though yeah yeah no
totally yeah I'm not trying to come off
as uh I know yeah yeah I mean there's
nothing wrong with wanting to be
comfortable anyone who's anyone who's
ever like who looks like me and goes and
sees a stand a standing toilet I'm like
hell no and that's not even like bad by
like a lot of Standards right that's
pretty like normal so what are you
complaining about at least there's a
toilet yeah yeah
a lot of I know [__] a lot of British
people who wouldn't [__] dare [__] in
a standing toilet hell no I'll hold it
no yeah no I think I think I think every
person is allowed to have you know their
standards for travel and you know I
think there's no real like reason to be
judgmental about that because that's
that's on them I don't think you
actually stand while you [__] in that I
know that you you yeah
just going like release